I'm going to talk about China's maritime
militia and international law
implications so the maritime militia is
an auxilary force composed primarily of
fishing vessel cooperatives that work in
conjunction with the People's Liberation
Army Navy and other Chinese government
departments in order to advance or
further the interests of China so this
is a group that is that has economic
motives to fish but also has an auxilary
function and all of law consists of two
different types of of bodies you first
have evidence or information or facts
and then you have the actual legal
doctrine and so first what I'll cover
are the facts and these facts are
derived from the China maritime studies
Institute research on the Chinese
maritime militia which is done at the
Naval War College and what they have
done is looked at original Chinese
language government sources to derive
this information and so all of my facts
are taken from the good work of the
people at CMS I the maritime militia is
is is best sort of represented by this
Hainan provincial fishing industry
website which says casting government
fish and casting nets of sovereignty so
the maritime militia is very much
intertwined with the Chinese government
and is an instrument of the government
it gets political support from Beijing
it also receives investment in
infrastructure and expansion including a
massive expansion in in the in Chinese
fishing vessel capacity which is ironic
since we know that the South China Sea
is actually over fished and there's over
capacity not just in China which has the
world's largest fishing fleet of 200,000
vessels but also in some of the other
countries but this is in order to
support this auxilary function or this
secondary function they also are
are entitled to fuel subsidies extensive
paramilitary training they are eligible
for pensions if they're injured in the
line of duty for these auxilary or
militia functions they're provided
satellite communications and other
methods to be able to command and
control this force as a government
instrumentality and all of this is part
of an asymmetric law fair or asymmetric
tool of the government in order to
occupy and dominate the so-called gray
zone or this area that's uncomfortably
lying between peace and war during
wartime
the militia can can conduct a number of
different functions or missions
including intelligence surveillance and
reconnaissance concealment harassment
blockade envelopment and minesweeping
transportation island defense and
patrols and the militia is not a new
it's not a not a new event in fact after
World War two it was used primarily to
counter nationalist infiltration of the
mainland and then in 1974 it was
instrumental in the Battle of the
Paracel Islands in seizing the Paracel
Islands from Vietnam and this battle has
now been mythologized as as the first
sort of successful naval battle and also
the first successful major operation of
this combined civil and military force
to achieve the aims of the state right
now we're witnessing the maritime
militia involved in a number of
peacetime roles including at the core of
the so called cabbage strategy or gray
zone dominance also critical
infrastructure protection such as ports
and oil rigs and certainly rights
protection missions or missions to
vindicate or advance the the the claimed
rights of China primarily based upon
historic rights harassment of four
vessels foreign vessels that are both
warships as well as civilian vessels
again is our including this instant in
incident here where a fishing vessel was
able to net a some countries on unmanned
underwater vehicle and then deliver it
to Chinese authorities there's also now
growing suspicion that the maritime
militia may be involved in interference
with submarine cables as well as of
course what we're most familiar with
which is its role in power projection
I'll focus on just one of these
cooperatives which is the Sagnier Fugen
fisheries company and it was founded in
2001 and it's quickly grown since then
it it launched in 2011 a 3,000 tonne
fishery supply and command and control
ship that it's used or operated in
conjunction with fisheries vessels to to
project power and to harass foreign
ships so in 2010 for example this large
command and control ship led a flotilla
of 29 vessels around a number of the
features in the vicinity of the Spratly
Islands including fiery cross reef subi
reef mischief reef and operating in
formation steaming and with command and
control from the large ship and then
upon their return they went through
recognition ceremonies arrival
ceremonies citations for bravery on
behalf of the state this is the same
group by the way that was involved in
the in the hys y98 one cabbage tactics
or cabbage strategy to protect that
critical asset that was placed in the
disputed waters and that was involved
with Vietnam drove away a number of
Vietnam Vietnamese vessels that were
protesting the arrival of this oil rig
in Viet Nam's exclusive economic zone
and this is also the group that was
involved in two other incidents the Binh
Minh 2 and the Viking 2 in 2011 it's
going on even today just about a month
ago via
seized a vessel that was disguised as a
fishing boat but in fact was a tanker
with a hundred thousand litres of diesel
fuel on board that was being used to
supply illicitly supply fuel to fishing
vessels that were operating in Viet
Nam's exclusive economic zone the
Philippines has also been subject to
this same fishing cooperative maritime
militia tactics specifically and most
recently in second Thomas shoal in 2014
when this the 8161 the 3,000 tonne
command and control ship led seven large
phu gong trawlers to try to intercept
the resupply of the beer the BRP sierra
madre which is this derelict former US
warship that the philippines has
grounded on the reefs there at second
Thomas shoal in order to in order to
sort of resist a Chinese encroachment
also just a month ago or six weeks ago
or so
Malaysia experienced what appears to be
maritime militia when a hundred Chinese
fishing vessels were operating around
South laconia Shoals offshore of Sarawak
that far south and the Malaysia maritime
enforcement agency and the Royal
Malaysian Navy encountered all of these
fishing vessels that had no flags and no
apparent registration a hundred vessels
and yet they were operating in
conjunction with two Chinese Coast Guard
ships Indonesia as well again about six
weeks ago in Indonesia was involved with
the this incident the Quaife a one zero
zero seven eight and eight crew that
were arrested for illegal ship illegal
fishing in the Natuna islands EEZ and
the vessel towline was cut by Chinese
coast guard vessel these Indonesia the
Ministry of maritime affairs and
Fisheries has had several incidents
where it
where its operations against illegal
fishing illegal Chinese fishing have
been disrupted by Chinese Coast Guard
ships including ships that these
fisheries law enforcement vessels 310
and 311 that have actually pointed
weapons at the Indonesian vessels and
it's interesting that this these two
ships 310 and 311 continue to sort of
crop up in incidents in this one
incidents in March of 2013 the fisheries
law enforcement vessel 310 demanded the
release of captured fishermen that had
been fishing illegally and in that
instance it used sirens and bridge to
bridge communications as well as
apparently satellite communications
jamming equipment to prevent the
Indonesian forces from contacting their
headquarters and in that incident as
well as in all the incidents actually
Indonesia backed down until this most
recent one in 2016 so that adds a new
sort of cyber warfare wrinkle to the
maritime militia that apparently they're
capable in some instances of of
operating in tandem with the Coast Guard
and preventing communications between
but between other forces and their
national leaders it's not just the South
China Sea but it's also in the East
China Sea Korea has encountered Chinese
fishing vessels and and maritime militia
in this case you can see here in the
photograph that Chinese vessels have
lashed all of their ships together in
order to impede boarding by the Republic
of Korea Coast Guard Japan has faced
similar challenges around the waters of
the Senkaku Islands and of course the
United States on a number of occasions
has encountered vessels which have which
have confirmed ties to the maritime
militia particularly this trawler eighty
three ninety nine that you see here that
was involved in the USNS impecable
incident that was the 2009 incident when
the United States impeccable which is a
u.s. navy auxilary warship was
conducting military surveys
in the Chinese exclusive economic zone
and it was surrounded by government
vessels as well as trawlers that have
been that have been linked as members of
the maritime militia in an effort to try
to impede those military activities so
with that I'll turn now toward the legal
implications and with the legal
implications it's important to keep in
mind that there's two bodies of law that
would apply there's a there's a a law of
naval warfare that would a flood that
would apply during periods of armed
conflict and then there's the peacetime
law of the sea or the United Nations
Convention on the law of the sea which
sort of serves as the constitution for
the world's oceans and under that
peacetime regime vessels may may be
flagged in any state but whatever state
carries that flag they the the state has
a duty of implementing internationally
accepted standards and so what I would
argue or suggest is that the maritime
militia in practice so far has not
complied with these internationally
accepted standards so in peacetime it's
important to remember that in the UN
Convention on the law of the sea the
flag state has important rights as well
as corresponding duties so the flag
state has a right to register vessels
and have those vessels fly its flag and
then those ships are free to use the
global Commons and travel throughout the
world but flag states also have
corresponding duties which sometimes are
not as as strongly observed we see this
in the phenomenon of open registries or
flag states of convenience but it also
appears to be a feature of the maritime
militia where the flag state has failed
to exercise effective jurisdiction or
effective and exclusive control over the
maritime militia and has not observed
international rules and it has failed to
investigate incidents or cooperate with
other states to find out what has
occurred
and it is also failed to to monitor
administrative technical and social
matters and make sure that the crew are
trained and operate in accordance with
international standards
well what standards are we talking about
in particular there's the collision
regulations or the International
Convention for collision regulations and
I've highlighted just a couple of them
here as as I talked about it you can see
that this is a Chinese maritime militia
a cargo ship that's bearing down and
actually sank a Vietnamese fishing
vessel but the collision regulations
have a a number of internationally
accepted standards and those standards
apply both to warships as well as
merchant vessels and they include rules
six seven and eight which I've
highlighted here which is the obligation
or the duty to maintain a safe speed
rule seven is the duty to avert any sort
of risk of collision that is to take
affirmative steps to avoid collision and
then rule eight is even stronger
language which is that that every
possible means must be taken to avoid a
collision here you see apparently just
the opposite of that where a maritime
militia vessel actually sank a
Vietnamese fishing vessel there is some
suggestion that the maritime militia may
be involved in submarine cable cutting
there's less direct evidence but but I
think that it's probably it will
probably more will come to light in any
event merit submarine cables are
responsible for about 95 percent of
global telecommunications and of course
everything that we do from from banking
to communications is linked to submarine
cables it all goes under the water
rather than through satellite because
satellite is still far too expensive and
the bandwidth is limited China is by far
the global leader in what are called
politely cable faults which are which
are broken
broken submarine cables and the
principal responsibility lies with
Chinese fishing vessels so there may be
instances particularly in cases of
inadvertent dragged anchor where it
might be inadvertent although it also
could be a purposeful campaign in any
event it is somewhat telling that
there's not been a single civil case
against a Chinese fishing vessel for a
broken submarine cable even though they
are the principal agent for those
incidents if so this would be
inconsistent with a long-standing and
and multi-dimensional regime or legal
set of rules for submarine cables going
back to 1884 which says that all vessels
should stand clear of areas of submarine
cables including of vessels that are
that are repairing or that are
maintaining submarine cables so the
vessels that are maintaining and
repairing submarine cables actually have
a right of way under the collision
regulations and the UN Convention on the
law of the sea and other multilateral
conventions and those rules do not
appear to have been observed in several
instances that involve maritime militia
in the few minutes remaining I'll to
also talk about the law of naval warfare
and this is that body of law that
applies during periods of armed conflict
the problem that the militia pose is
that it violates one of the core
fundamental principles of the law of
armed conflict also known as
international humanitarian law and that
is that humanitarian law is designed to
protect civilians and civilian objects
such as regular workers schools
hospitals and also fishing vessels so
this is the principle of distinction
that is that states have a duty to make
these civilian objects distinct and
separate from its Armed Forces and
that's exactly the opposite of what a
maritime militia does which tends to
blur or merge the civilian forces into
the
the Armed Forces what this does is it
exploits a gap in international law
between peace and war and this gap was
really exposed in the US v Nicaragua
case at the International Court of
Justice that my dear colleague Nong
mentioned in in her presentation and
that is that under the UN Charter states
have a right of self-defense if they are
subject to an armed attack or in the
equally valid French translation armed
aggression so if a state commits armed
aggression which is forbidden and
crosses the line of this article to
paragraph four of the UN Charter a state
at some point thereafter enjoys the
right of self-defense but what the
Nicaragua case said is that it's not a
bright line in fact the u.s. lost that
case because the u.s. claimed that once
this line is crossed and that that a
state is subject to an armed attack that
immediately triggers this right of
self-defense the court disagreed and
said no there's actually this gap that
even though a country is subject to an
armed attack it may not exercise the
right of self-defense if that armed
attack does not reach a sufficient
gravity or have sufficient scale and
effects of a conventional attack what
this does in the in my view and in the
view of some scholars is that it creates
this gap which seems to license this
low-level asymmetric armed coercion or
armed attack and therefore it actually
is ripe for exploitation by a force such
as the maritime militia that comfortably
operates and dominates inside this gap
achieving its ends while avoiding
full-fledged conflict thank you very
much